je vous souhaite la bienvenue
bonjour aujourd'hui le collège adopté et
c'est à dix et trois avis sur les
demandes de candidature de l'ukraine à
l'ue moldova et de la géorgie nous à
vous avons adopté ces avis après une
évaluation attentive des mérites de
chacune de ces demandes en utilisant
vous le savez les critères de copenhague
et de madrid
vous le savez certainement aussi
il s'agit des critères politiques
économiques et
leurs capacités aussi de ces pays a
prospéré sur notre marché intérieur
compétitif je vais commencer par
l'ukraine la commission recommande au
conseil tout d'abord que l'ukraine se
voit accorder une perspective européenne
ensuite que l'ukraine est souvent
accorder le statut de candidat
bien entendu sur la base que ce pays
effectuera une davantage de réformes
importantes
permettez moi de présenter en détail
nous recommandations d'après la
commission l'ukraine a prouvé clairement
le souhait de le pays et l'une
l'engagement et pratiques du pays à
respecter les valeurs et des normes
européennes
le cren avant la guerre c'était déjà et
langer sur sa voie vers l'union
européenne
durant huit années à présent
et se rapprocher de plus en plus de
notre union comme vous le savez nous
avions l'accord d'association depuis
2016 et avec cela le cren a déjà pu
appliquer
plus ou moins 70% de l'acquis européen
les règles normes et standards de lieux
le cren participent à des programmes
européens très importants tels que le
programme horizon ou erasmus
l'ukraine à dispose d'une démocratie
parlementaire robuste une démocratie
présidentielle
c'est une administration publique qui
fonctionne parfaitement qui a permis et
qui permet encore le fonctionnement du
pays durant cette guerre ne le savons
parce que nous travaillons en étroite
collaboration avec l'administration
ukrainienne nous savons que la réforme
de décentralisation qui a été adopté par
le pays est une franche réussite
nous voyons les résultats des régions et
des municipalités mais même dans cette
situation exceptionnelle de guerre et la
réponse de modernisation de
l'administration se poursuit
l'ukraine est composé d'une société
civile est très active et très vivante
le système électoral ukrainien et justes
et libres
tels que l'élu critères de odiah sont
respectées un système éducatif bien
développé aussi nous avons à nous
admirons les compétences numériques de
ce pays ainsi que les infrastructures
numériques qui sont en place
et si nous intéressons inde économique
bien entendu nous devons nous intéresser
la situation économique avant la guerre
le cren a prouvé qu'il y avait un niveau
de déficit et saint leu 2 % et une dette
publique inférieure
50% ce qui est aussi une bonne chose
donc le cren un déjà entrepris des
démarches pour devenir
une économie de marché fonctionnant à
plein régime cette importante parce que
bien entendu l'ukraine ne doit être en
mesure d'être intégrée totalement en
marché l'anc européen vous savez que
livre le travail sur
la solution de l'ukraine dans plusieurs
secteurs le secteur transport nous avons
un accord transport pour intégrer aussi
les systèmes énergétiques davantage vous
souviendrez que même après le début de
la guerre
le réseau électrique l'ukrainien a été
relié au réseau européen
donc toutes ces démarches se font dans
le bon sens en parallèle bien entendu
nous savons que encore d'autres choses
doit être effectuée sur l'état de droit
par exemple
l'ukraine a beaucoup avancé
et a pu mettre en place les institutions
nécessaires pour que le judiciaire
fonctionne de façon efficace ainsi que
les institutions pour le contrôle des
procureurs
faudrait présent se concentrer sur
l'accélération de la sélection des juges
de la cour constitutionnelle ainsi que
les membres du haut conseil de justice
pour ce qui est de la lutte contre la
corruption on l'ukraine a aussi beaucoup
de congrès c'est pour mettre sur pied
les organes nécessaires de lutte contre
la corruption donc à présent il faudra
se concentrer sur la désignation du
nouveau responsable des procureurs de
lutte contre la corruption ainsi que le
nouveau directeur du bureau enquêtes de
lutte contre la corruption d'autres
termes les organes de lutte contre la
corruption existe et de voies doivent à
présent être totalement opérationnel les
oligarques à présent l'ukraine a adopté
une législation audacieuse sur les
oligarques et c'est le seul pays du
partenariat oriental a d'ailleurs qui
agit de la sorte c'est une bonne chose
là aussi à présent il faut passer à l
exécution nous souhaitons obtenir des
résultats sur le terrain pour les droits
fondamentaux l'ukraine a pu respecter
80% des recommandations de la commission
de venise ce qui reste à faire c'est
l'adoption de la législation sur les
minorités nationales donc pour résumer
beaucoup a été accompli
mais bien entendu il ya encore des
tâches importantes à accomplir je me
suis entretenu de tout cela avec le
président il inscrit et avec le premier
serait général lorsque j'étais à qui
arrive il y a de cela dix jours
la réponse du président ce qui est très
très parlante à lundi même si nous
n'étions pas candidat à l'union
européenne ce sont des réformes qui sont
nécessaires et qui sont bonnes pour
notre pays donc il faudra
effectuer parce que c'est bon pour la
démocratie et le craignait alors bien
entendu que tout ne peut pas être
atteints tant que
la guerre est présent dans le pays mais
un grand nombre de ces points peuvent
être traitées malgré trop donc pour
conclure sur le cren
nous avons un message clair à savoir wii
l'ukraine mérite une perspective
européenne
oui mick rennes devrait être accueilli
en tant que pays candidat
en partant de la base que du travail
important a été effectué mais qu'il ya
encore beaucoup de choses à faire
toute cette procédure dépend des mérites
avait donc nous respectons les règles et
les progrès dépendent totalement de
l'ukraine
tout cela est entre les mains de
l'ukraine et cela permettra l'ukraine de
façonner son propre avenir